che male che male mi sono fatto porca
vacca ma da tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo partito
noi siamo forti su fall guys e quindi
facciamo leva su questo non so le mie
dita speriamo che sia oggi la giornata
vi riporto in a corona speriamo mi porti
alla vittoria non ci spero ma ci spero
si parte sul sito la mappa più di alta
di tutti benissimo la partenza è sempre
ottima ovviamente sto facendo solo si sa
ora gas senza che caccia dirvi hanno
messo in rotation seesaw porco demonio
ed è orribile e la odio con tutto me
stesso
allora mi serve un po di concentrazione
da parte di tutti visto che porco del
demonio chi mi ha tenuto chi è stata
tele chi è quel maledetto che di stacco
la spina del computer solo ultimo chi mi
ha tenuto la lotta allo talk ragazzi sta
staskin porta sfiga secondo me perché
tutti quanti vogliono grab armi poi
perché sono uno dog qui non va proprio
benissimo secondo me furgoni nardò arda
poi vabbè e si somma il problema e non è
volgare bensì solo e questa mappa del
demonio infernale no ma la prendo con
filosofia ogni volta sussista o ragazzi
tranquilla e proprio il gioco che mi
porta a capire che io non sono fatto per
gioco al centro procura però mi mette
allegria di the ice ragazzi questa è già
meglio perché design è una cagata
però non voglio sottovalutarla per il
fatto appunto che oi la skin dello dog è
proprio questa che potrebbe portare
sfiga quindi vediamo se mediax è
fattibile anche con questo schifo per
adesso lo toghe sta funzionando era
gabini niente male
perfetto bellissimo tutto a posto e
siamo arrivati terno quarti che non è
male
sfatiamo subito che non funzionava bene
l'inizio per adesso tutto ok dai ragazzi
il 40 quali file e vediamo adesso so
tutti i cactus sono l'unico top
sono emozionato jinx ed siamo il 40 per
giustamente 20 contro 20
vediamo se la mia squadra e in genere fa
sempre caga la mia squadra in cigs fa
sempre cagare sono molto più bravo a
schivare che a colpire gli altri quindi
proverò a schivare i ragazzi le scopo
dall'altra parte
toglietegli fate schifo c'è un jeans
attore di lato anche dico attenzione
perfetto non sono riuscito a salire semi
gene sano è finita perché ci sono
praticamente solo io qua che posso fare
la differenza non gli altri fanno cagare
tubo cinzano è finita e ragazzi oh mio
dio ma basta questo addio c'era un
casino attenzione sono quasi l'ultimo da
jing fare attenzione perfetto non mi
hanno jeans a è la prima volta che il
video credo in video non siamo in
successo che non mi hanno già in stato
fantastico perché rimanere ultimi jeans
ed è l'unico modo ragazzi a 321 vincola
in 11 quindi è un
ti porti quali credi pesanti come sia
per un azzecco mai la strada giusta
all'inizio saranno in tantissimi essere
minati speriamo non è di non esserci nel
metodo perche non avrebbe senza
attenzione di certo la piattaforma buon
occhio occhio
occhio che qua occhio perfetto
buonissimo buonissimo non è stato male
non col monte in quindi uscirà formante
in vediamo di perdere il polmone ragazzi
come sempre andiamo per la prossima raga
allora football non è la finale lune a
finale ci ha fatto fare una semifinale
su fall bolli hingis pari la squadra
gialla meno players quindi io sarò nella
sua da gialla vediamo di perderla almeno
con onore c'è una palla che potrebbe
farci vincere la partita che è quella
del che vale quando segni con quella
valle 5 potrebbe aver senso le stiamo
tanto fanno cagare i miei compagni
iordache è molto semplice però ragazzi
non date mai per scontata la vittoria
perché all'ultimo giro possono fregarvi
dorda cv fregano all'ultimo giro è
sempre all'ultima porta volevo intendere
perché se rimanete indietro di una porta
sola avete forse già perso quindi
rimanete sempre davanti ma non primi
perché qualcuno perché arrivò a dire
testare le porte quindi quella è molto
importante
lo vediamo perfetto la prima nella prima
scena difficilissimo beccare la cosa
sbagliata dal terremoto suina ecco
adesso sono morto perché tutti mi
stavano addosso non riusciva però non
sono matto ok
l'ultima porta perfetto non male non
male sfatiamo il mito dello dog ragazzi
sfatiamo il mito della toga che non
vince mai
sfatiamo lo perfetto quale file next
quanto siamo 41 allora quella in diver
hit parade e va bene dai parenti mi
piace come quella degli orologi che
roteano praticamente un ricordo ma il
nome forse un po meno ma è sempre molto
carina ricordatevi che andare lì sotto
non è una penalità potete andare 18 e
corrente uguale quindi se vedete non c'è
spazio andate praticamente risolto
adesso c'è spazio quindi vado occhio al
casinò ragazzi o cotti al casinò
perfetto qua raga tutti vanno sempre al
centro andare di lato non è male perché
anche di lato sia aprire sono una
dominato mesi aveva prima cento alzino
finale però va bene allora l'ex co
perfetto 30 remaining e quindi va stare
attenti ragazzi perfetto siamo arrivati
al pelo per il suo cascata se non fosse
cascato avrei rischiato tanto ai ragazzi
occhio qua perché sembra e maledetta
stampa perché non sembra che sei avanti
ma non lo sei come caschi è un casino è
next ragazzi 30 reining obsil jesino la
mia preferita in assoluto questa ragazzi
di gruppo e lo dico sempre è la mia
preferita in assoluto dopo fourball
forconi mi piace quando non ho quando
vinco quando la scheda la sua da scarsa
in realtà quando siamo in maggioranza mi
piace però si daisy e la migliore in
assoluto secondo me bisogna rimanere
sempre lo dico sempre equidistanti a
livello di mappa tipo di qua non ci sono
dei rossi e di qua non c'era 100 nostro
di gialli nicchia ok c'è questa qua
porca vacca quel aveva 5 gianni fanno
cagare ragazzi ok quindi devo portare
avanti io la mia squadra se non la
vinciamo perfetto non mi entra il
dove fa cagare non rientra nei cerchi
però vabbè fa niente bravo bravo giallo
bravo giallo proprio giallo weil i
ragazzi ottimo la mia squadra si è fatta
valere alla fine poi hanno giocato bene
anche gli altri dopo
all'inizio non ho 73 punti subsea daisy
non li ho forse neanche mai fatte
funzione è cascato questo bravo colpisce
tantissimo abbiamo fatto 80 punti quasi
suo psi lei si è fantastico non mi era
mai successo ex crumble può essere
oppure block bardi oppure fourball però
non lo so cosa no ragazzi cosa ma che
cacchio di te non ragazzi impossibile a
parte il fatto che io sono altissimo
quindi in job showdown perdo perché mi
min castro in mezzo le lancette pazzesca
una quanta gente non raga finale sta
roba davvero senza la parola ma se
pagato il gioco non è mai successo
soraga assurdo speriamo di arrivare tra
gli ultimi a questo punto dai parchi
crolla lì speriamo veramente di arrivare
tra gli ultimi raga perché i venti quali
finale pesa 20 finale è tesa madonna già
che siamo in un non so cosa sia successo
ve lo giuro il mio con il mio
personaggio non si è mosso a un certo
punto il mio personaggio non si è mosso
e io vi giuro che ho provato a saltare
l'antipersonaggio facciamo così ed è
caduto giù una finale in 20 non me l'ha
mai successa prossima volta degli host
riusciamo anche a vincerla magari
chiedere il canale lasciate un commento
e niente abbiamo scola non abbiamo stato
definito che non si può vincere quello
dogs non è che lo smog non si può
vincere ma proprio perché è più alto
quindi a più hitbox semplicemente cioè
che viene colpito più facilmente gli si
chiede anche lei ha lasciato un bel mi
piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo vito era ragazzi
[Musica]